in recent years but especially over the
past year we've seen the rise in what
some have called the body count
discourse and this is a discussion about
body counts specifically the body counts
of women more specifically whether a man
should care if the woman he's dating has
a high body count and of course when we
say body count we don't mean that a man
is dating a woman who's a former Marine
Corps sniper with 87 confirmed kills if
you're below the age of 40 you probably
already know that body count in this
context means the number of people
you've slept with a woman with a high
body count is a woman who has had sex
with lots of men accompanying these
conversations are usually videos where
random YouTubers go out into the street
or out to some college campus and they
ask people about their body counts and
in many videos you can see young women
proudly declare body counts in the
dozens or even hundreds um some men
including a number of influential men
have have been pointing out that these
Skyhigh numbers these Ted Bundy level
body counts are pretty disgusting and
speaking of Ted Bundy I I I uh you know
I could probably do an hourong segment
simply on the fact that the phrase body
count has come to refer to sexual
Conquest there's immense psychological
significance to be found in the fact
that a term that once referred to
killing people now in modern society
applies to sex that's a that's a
different conversation though suffices
to say for now that it's not a positive
development doesn't say anything good
about modern culture in any case all of
this discussion about body count has led
to a backlash from the other side where
feminists and other assorted Nar duells
have uh admonished men for having this
conversation at all and insisted that we
shouldn't care about body counts in the
first place that was the case made this
week in the Atlantic by feminist writer
Helen Lewis in her article titled nobody
should care about a woman's body count
and she Begins by uh setting the stage
with a story of rising misogyny quote uh
ever since Elon musk's lackes began
fiddling with the algorithms of X
formerly Twitter I've noticed a distinct
shift in in the content that is pushed
onto users my 4 UT tab is now a nest of
Trad wives shoplift in videos and that
guy who has strong opinions on trouser
creases it's also home to the kind of
old-fashioned misogyny that I once
thought was on the decline now let me
step to the side here to say that um I
can translate uh uh this paragraph from
feminist into English prior to musk
taking over Twitter every social media
company in the world had worked hard to
set up a bubble for people like Helen
Lewis by suppressing and censoring the
very normal Common Sense perspectives of
normal Common Sense people but in the
musk era Twitter no longer does that
which means means that she has she she
has to encounter those perspectives
again she thought they were on the
decline because that's the fantasy world
that big Tech had created for her and
she was never smart enough or skeptical
enough to question it so that's really
what's going on here continuing one of
the obsessions of the worst parts of
this group call uh call them the
influential jerk web is body count
discourse in which women always women
are shame for the number of sexual
partners they've had the phrase is
quickly uh has gained popularity so
quickly that Jason Derulo has just
released a new song about it now Derulo
is okay with a high body count quote all
that ass must be good at math he
observes but others are not uh quote a
lot of the world's problems could be
fixed if women walked around with their
body count on their foreheads the
professional kickboxer turned sexist
influencer Andrew Tate said in one viral
clip these men provide gen Z and younger
Millennials with a very old template for
masculinity filtered through the new
visual grammar and vocabulary of YouTube
twitch and Tik Tok now she goes on for a
while longer talking about all the
bastardly men who have made an issue out
of the fact that a certain significant
preponderance of modern single women
have had sex with entire stadiums full
of men but she does find a bright spot a
glimmer of hope towards the end quote
two other things are worth noting about
the body count discour discourse the
first is that some people on the edges
of the influential jerk web have
consciously rejected its exhausting
sexual monitoring of women the left-wing
streamer Destiny for example was raised
Catholic but is now in an open
relationship yes if only more men could
be pathetic disgraced cuckolds like
leftwing streamer Destiny if only we
could we could uh you know if only
that's what we could all if we only we
could actually live in the world that
Helen thought we lived in before Elon
Musk destroyed the Illusion by lifting
all the shadow bands if
only now if you're the perceptive type
at least more perceptive than Helen
Lewis you might notice that although
we've read chunks of this article we
haven't gotten to the part where Helen
explains why men shouldn't care about
body counts that's because she never
does explain it she makes not one single
argument to support her ass assertion
that nobody should care about a woman's
body count she simply asserts it she
declares it and expects that assertion
to somehow carry weight and this is
always the strategy of leftwing
feminists they act as though their
viewpoints no matter how deranged or
stupid are are self-evident and
therefore don't need explaining or
defending they just repel down into the
middle of the conversation and declare
no you're all wrong here's what you
really should think and then and then
they they leave and they expect us to
respond by say oh that's what we should
think well okay then we'll change our
viewpoints immediately if that's what
Helen says then it must be true Helen
would never lie to
us but unfortunately for Helen it
doesn't work that way and this is the
first point before we talk about why men
care about body count the most important
thing to understand is that they do they
simply do this is something that men
care about you might might think that
they we shouldn't care about it you
might demand that we not care about it
but people can't be hectored into not
caring about something it's hard enough
to convince someone to not care about
something but the feminists as
established aren't even trying to do
that they're just issuing
demands and those demands can't be met
even if we wanted to meet them which we
don't you can't just tell someone don't
care about that anymore oh okay I'll
just stop caring about it what we can't
we care about what we care about you
don't have to like it you don't have to
agree with it you don't have to care
about the same sorts of things but it is
what it is and in in some ways this is
maybe the best response to the other
side of this discussion especially
because they're not making any kind of
actual argument when a feminist starts
screeching that men shouldn't care about
this perhaps all we should say in
response is okay but we do deal with it
like we just do that's it but this is a
podcast so I can't just leave it there
especially because there are many valid
reasons why so many men do care about
this and why the ones who don't or claim
they don't should and first of all it
should be understood that the issue is
oftentimes not just a woman's body count
but also her current attitude about her
body count so what is most revolting to
a man is is a woman who has slept with
many men and rather than repenting of
those ways instead has this attitude
about it watch why do you think men care
about a woman's body count do you people
actually care about that men in general
if a man is asking my a body count he
can get who gives a oh my God that's so
stupid people actually ask that yes you
okay well then you're talking to the
wrong man if a man has ever asking you
about your body count you're talking to
the rod man and he can get like that's
so
stupid so can I ask you this then yeah
sure so what do you think about the
analogy if one key can open many locks
it's known as a master key as opposed to
if you have a lock that can be opened by
any key it's a lock I think that if an
if a woman is an analogy to you then
you're not ready to be talking to a
woman and you should probably get so if
a woman is a key to you talk to your mom
talk to your sister talk to your cousin
I don't know get a real F
life and get thank you and a woman is
not a key
thank
you the man can get effed she says
repeatedly and it's true that if the
man's talking to her he probably can uh
because it sounds like she's probably
doing a lot of that now that right there
is the absolute worst combination for a
man you have a woman who we can assume
based on her defensiveness has had sex
with a significant number of men and who
far from repenting of it instead flaunts
it proudly defending it in that
screeching vulgar tone that men find uh
utterly uh disgusting really everything
about the video is repulsive to most men
it's in a literal sense disgusting it
triggers our disgust reflex and once
again that's simply not something you
can scold us into
changing why is it disgusting why do men
care about body count well let's go
through a brief list of a few key
reasons number one number one number one
is is is a very is the most practical
concern probably if a woman has been
with lots of men the chance that she has
some kind of disease is much higher the
association with promiscuity and
dirtiness uncleanliness is not arbitrary
it's not socially constructed neither is
the association with virginity and
Purity there's a spiritual connotation
to these things of course but there's
also the physical sense as well so when
a man hears that a woman has been with
25 guys or whatever one of the very
first things he will think is that the
woman probably has herpes or something
and this is not an unreasonable
assumption now Beyond these practical
and medical concerns when a man hears
that a woman is promiscuous this will
lead him to rightly question her loyalty
you know if she has a habit or or maybe
I should say her capacity for
loyalty if she has a habit of jumping in
bed with every other guy she meets then
um he's going to worry that this low
impulse control this habit of following
her carnal desires above all will
increase the likelihood that she'll
continue in that behavior even after
making a commitment to him so a man
wants to be able to say about his woman
that is it is unimaginable that she
would jump into bed with some random guy
she meets at the gym or whatever like
even if she was single she wouldn't do
that that's what a man wants to be able
to say that even if she was single she
wouldn't do that that's just she not
that kind of
person but if the man knows that if she
was single she would do that then the
man will worry justifiably so that she
will do that even when she's not
single
but even if she refrains from hooking up
with random men while in a relationship
with him her propensity WS that behavior
calls into question her morals and her
values a man wants a woman who is chased
self-controlled dignified
classy and and and not just because that
makes it less likely that she's diseased
and not just because that makes it less
likely that she'll cheat on him even
though those are two big factors but
also even more fundamentally because
that's simply the right way to be a
lenus woman is a disordered woman it's a
woman who who does not have the value
system that men admire and find
attractive now it's a cliche perhaps but
a man
really does want a woman that he can
bring home and introduce to his mom you
when I first introduced my my now wife
to my parents years ago uh my mom uh
pulled me aside within within about an
hour of meeting her and said we really
like her she's great and that's when I
knew I wanted to marry her because uh
and and I'd only known her for a few
weeks at that point but when you get
that kind of endorsement from the people
in your life that you look to for advice
and they see this woman and they say
this is a very good woman uh that that
means a lot to a man
you ever read the fine print that
appears when you start in browsing in
incognito mode it says that your your
activity might still be visible to your
employer your school or your internet
service provider to actually stop people
from monitoring your online activity you
need to do what I do and use expressvpn
think about all the times you've used
Wi-Fi at a coffee shop Hotel even a
friend's house without Express VPN every
site you visit could be logged by the
Admin of that Network and that's still
true even when you're in incognito mode
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data reroutes it through
a network of secure server servers so
that your private online activity stays
private Express VN works on all your
devices it's super easy to use the app
has one button you tap it to connect and
your browsing activity is secure it's as
simple as that stop letting strangers
invade your online privacy protect
yourself at expressvpn.com Walsh show
use my Link at expressvpn.com walow to
get three extra months free that's
expressvpn.com mat Walsh show now the
other thing to keep in mind is that is
that men are competitive by Nature so we
want to pursue a woman and if we if we
win her affection we want to feel as
though we've won a great prize this kind
of works out because women on the other
end want to be treated as a great prize
you know the term trophy wife has a
negative connotation but the truth is
that in a sense every man wants a trophy
wife and every woman wants to be a
trophy that is to say a man wants to be
proud of his wife wants to be proud to
be seen with her and a wife wants her
husband to be proud in that way but but
a man will feel that he he can't have
this kind of PR pride and a promiscuous
woman because for one thing her
promiscuity has likely damaged her
reputation you know the man will feel
ashamed to put a ring on the finger of a
woman who half the guys in town have
already had a turn with it's very it's a
very shameful thing it's embarrassing to
him and more deeply still if a woman if
a woman does not treat herself as a
great prize if she has given herself
away for nothing over and over again
then how can the man see her any
differently if you treat yourself as
cheap other people are not going to see
you as high
value women who give away their intimacy
who offer it up to anyone who comes
along are sending a message about how
they perceive their own
value and Men hear that message and they
respond
accordingly now we spent all this time
talking about the body counts of women
but uh you know you might ask what about
the body counts of men should women care
if a man has a high body count and yes
they should most of these same arguments
apply in the reverse
but here we're specifically talking
about what men value and should value in
a woman that's the
conversation and I'm here to tell you
that men value loyalty they value good
morals they value virtue they they value
dignity they value class they value
Grace they Value
Beauty they want a high value woman who
treats herself that way and projects
that to the world they want a Woman They
can show off they want a woman they can
bring home the mom
and and if you're a single woman and you
want to be all those things to a man
then then don't go around sleeping with
random guys pretty
simple so this is all why the people who
deny that quote unquote body count
matters are today canceled thanks for
checking out this video if you'd like to
listen to my full podcast on the go you
can check out the Matt wall show on
Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
get your podcast